avec les sept autobus 100% électrique
est le fruit de 10 ans de travail avec
une intention réinventer le transport
scolaire
en fait au début on est allé avec un un
concept d'innovation globale sur le
véhicule scolaire donc plus léger donc
puisqu'il a man être plus performants
moins d'entretien également non d'entre
nous on veut être certain que quand le
véhicule est vendu veiller sur l'arbre
[Musique]
cet indicatif sonore est un dispositif
de sécurité car le véhicule est trop
silencieux on n'entend pas venir
normalement commence à chauffer les
véhicules électriques le plus jamais
retourné un véhicule diesel
ça sent bon c'est plus silencieux
c'est on est beaucoup plus dans
l'autobus la majorité des professeurs m
il y actuellement 3000 autobus scolaire
lit on sur les routes la moitié au
québec
le reste aux etats unis californie est à
new york en ontario et en alberta
il sort cinq véhicules par jour de cette
usine de saint jérôme qui occupe
maintenant l'ancienne fabrique de patins
bauer d'un côté et autrefois bell
helicopter de l'autre une carrosserie en
fibre de verre plus légère plus large
aussi pour pouvoir y installer des
ceintures de sécurité obligatoire en
californie c'était l'idée de départ de
marc bédard avec ensuite celle du tout
électrique
il ya beaucoup d'innovations mais en
fait le chantier est construit dès le
départ et électriques
donc chacun des emplacements c'est fait
pour que ce soit face et l'entretenir
que l' équilibre des poids super
également donc ses chances ne jamais
défaut prédisait 3-1 retrofit comme on
dit aux inondations c'est vraiment un
champ électrique dès le début c'est un
peu ce qui fait la beauté les véhicules
qu'on fait le tout est pensé électrique
dès la première dès maintenant
seulement voilà un de ces autobus
électrique coûte deux fois plus cher
qu'un au diesel il y à des subventions à
l'achat mais les opérateurs d'autobus
scolaires qui ont des budgets serrés
bénéficie aussi de subventions ou diesel
et au propane pas logique disent les
écologistes d'un cadran finance l'achat
de diesel ou de combustibles fossiles
pour les commissions scolaires tout ça
mais qu'en même temps on ne peut ni
l'engagement d'abandonner l'utilisation
des combustibles fossiles d'une part
dans une contradiction flagrante mais en
métal là où on a le plus grand intérêt
au québec vers une tarification des
transports au bout de notre match de nos
possibilités nous tous les gains qu'on
pourra voir c'est comme si on sait que
c'est l'homme on n'agit pas alors là il
faut faire disparaître des subventions
aux combustibles fossiles points et
s'est même l'onu le demande de se
demander par tous alors il faut passer
de la parole aux actes ne plus financer
l'achat de diesel ou de d'autobus le
diesel est financé ce qui est la
solution à la crise climatique mais qui
est aussi un vraiment un et la relance
économique à la création d'emplois c'est
certain que quand les gouvernements
veulent encourager l'électrification des
transports
ce qu'il faut c'est permettent aux
opérateurs de faire l'investissement
initial et le des fils électriques
aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est
l'investissement initial la fin de la
coved c'est un moment clé pour lyon qui
voit s'envoler les commandes pour les
autobus scolaires et qui a de grandes
ambitions
on est moins quatre ans après on se dit
déjà que les ce cas là c'est comme
évident ça fonctionne bien là on est
rendu à un autre niveau
l'autre niveau c'est vraiment c'est les
caméras et les camions électriques ça
veut dire beaucoup de kilométrage
soixante quinze mille kilomètres par
année sans problème donc on est un
camion de vidange électrique avec la
benne électrique qui est fait par un de
nos partenaires
des camions pour l'élire fournisseurs
d'énergie par exemple pour hydro-québec
donc des camions nacelles tout à fait
avec un aux partenaires également qu'un
camion complètement électrique ou la
source d'approvisionnement électrique
ce sont nos batteries qui sont sur deux
camions et l'on ne plusieurs exemples
comme ça donc on est complètement passé
un autre niveau un autre niveau car il y
à un demi million d'autobus scolaires en
amérique du nord mais plus de 15
millions de camions lourds
ceux ci comptent une autonomie de 400 km
ils seront plus chères à l'achat mais
extrêmement plus économique à long terme
une fois qu'ils sont amortis mais daniel
breton un pionnier de la voiture
électrique voit les coûts baisser très
rapidement beaucoup de gens n'y
croyaient pas et peut-être des
compagnies de qui on riait ya quelques
années à peine
je me rappelle est en allemagne et
d'avoir des dirigeants d'entreprise se
moque littéralement dire une mosquée de
tesla
je pense qu'ils rient - c'est-à-dire
quand on voit que les avancées
technologiques entre autres fait à lire
avec karim sahib avec les appelle les
batteries solides qui vont devenir non
seulement moins cher plus dense
ça va ça va faire en sorte de principe
de rendre les véhicules plus légers
ça faisait que prendre la mer autonomie
d'à besoin de moins de poids moins de
volume tout se vaut faire en sorte de
créer une vraie révolution technologique
et ça c'est pas dans 10 à celle ci de
trois à cinq ans maximum
dernier produit de lyon le minibus
électriques idéal pour le transport
adapté
il peut l'être aussi pour rendre plus
flexible une flotte de transport urbain
en fonction des heures de fréquentation
de longue date loi dans les énergies des
transports bras présentement sa vraie
300 maisons et ont pris roi d'ys de
métal ça va être prêt d'ici 100 ans mais
dont la moitié presque 300 milles 3 dans
les transports et soit précisément c'est
beaucoup l'électrification des
transports
que ce soit pour les voitures les
camions des autobus donc on dit c'est un
bon vecteur de relance économique
là on est au 21ème siècle qu'on sort
d'une crise qui liés au réchauffement de
la planète sont ne dit pas si souvent
ben si on veut régler les problèmes on
n'a qu'à prendre les outils qui existent
dit solo mais ça il faut avoir le
courage de dbo
on a les outils on a les moyens on a de
besoin
alors allons-y les choses vont vite pour
lyon un démarrage il ya dix ans et des
autobus scolaires qui roule vraiment
depuis 2007 seulement on était jusqu'à
il ya environ un an et demi et au québec
en fait sources électriques au québec
qui vous électrifie tarder les critères